salut la semaine dernière j'étais à aix
en provence et en fait grâce au principe
de retours temporels je suis de retour
avec son provence et j'ai quelqu'un avec
moi c'est blandine tu sais pas qui est
blandine parce que tu sais qui tu sais
pas ce que tu m'as pris par la main dans
la rue il m'a dit de venir ça fait
vachement peur blandine c'est la
première abonnés c'est la première
d'entre vous à être venus me voir johnny
c'est quoi ton nom dans les commentaires
à chaud des jeunes il faut que nous tous
nous couvrent et donc elle est venue à
la première représentation ici avec ce
c'était mercredi soir avec quentin avec
son chéri c'est la première fois que je
rencontre une l'abonné danthine
je suis ravi lundi d'anciens numéros
ensemble oui ok on va se faire un truc
j'ai réfléchi à ça est-ce que tu as les
animaux non est-ce que tu avais des
animaux étant petit
non ça t'a jamais vue d'animaux mais don
cherry à des animaux se serait ok il a
un chien un chat et un poisson ce genre
de choses ok ah oui tout ça même le
poisson alors le chat mange et je savais
pas jusqu'à maintenant qu'il avait des
animaux confirme oui à savoir tout ça ok
on va jouer avec le chaton chaîne la
manière suivante tu prends la feuille
sur fait une boulette et tu la mets dans
ta main qui tient bien la boulette comme
ça pour qu'on la voit aussi à la caméra
s'est froissé et donc ça on imagine que
c'est une boulette avec lequel pourrait
jouer un chat tu vois virtuellement ok
je vais me retourner on va le voir et la
caméra et toi ce que tu vas faire c'est
que tu vas cacher la boulette 61 à
gauche soit dans ta main droite soit
dans ta poche va pouvoir faire ce que tu
veux ou tu la caf dans ta main gauche
dans la main droite ou dans ta poche car
quand c'est fait tu mais dès demain
comme ça les points vers le bas et
juridique c'est bon c'est bon
alors je te pose des questions à garat
un petit truc en plus ce qui est amusant
c'est qu'à partir de maintenant tu vas
décidé de toujours me mentir ou toujours
me dire la vérité c'est toi qui décide
donc en tout un temps de réflexion dans
ta tête tu dis ok je dirais que la
vérité je dirai que des mensonges le
coup dimanche dit la vérité ça j'en sais
rien et c'est ça la difficulté du truc
tu as pris ta décision dans ta tête
première question est ce que la boulette
est dans tes mains à la l'accrétion moi
aussi deuxième question est ce que la
boulette et dans ta main gauche c'était
assez intéressant
je t'avais dit deux questions est un
truc en plus le truc en plus va être le
suivant je me retourne et de nouveau
c'est la boulette et dans ta main droite
disons que tu la mets dans ta poche si
elle est dans ta poche tu la mets dans
ta main gauche s'ils allaient dans ta
main gauche n'a pas de mouvement un
frère du coup fait semblant de faire
quelque chose quand même
pour maintenir en irak tu me dis quand
c'est bon
c'est bon si j'ai bien compté réaction
j'ai pris en compte le temps et les
mouvements de café je dirais que la
boulette et dante à ma gauche
est-ce que j'ai mon ouïe et la foule
était là c'est la boulette de ton chat
du chat de ton copain alors cette
boulette elle symbolise et le jeu qu'on
peut avoir avec le avec ton copain est
ce que tu pourrais imaginer maintenant
en tendant la main comme ça que c'est le
chat de ton chéri de chaque canton
pourrait imaginer pour imaginer en fait
que qu'il a la forme du chat et comme et
qu'il y avait son nom de tatouer dessus
ok et je pense que ce chan a un nom
particulier
je pense que ce châle à hasnon à
consonance un peu pays du sud comme les
contre le colonel un peu ce genre de
choses
c'est pas de ça me direz je dirais que
ça finit en tête en consonance en faire
des choses un peu oui c'est vrai et je
dirais que le chat de quentin s'appelle
j'ai dit avec un 3/6 là mais je dirai
tout ce qui est quelque chose comme ça
c'est pas loin c'était quoi ce truc
sookie et j'ai dit tout ce qu'ils n'ont
même pas mal moi je dis que j'aime on
sait tous c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
je dis grand merci beaucoup platine
c'est ce que nous faisons pas sûr qu'ils
soutiendraient pas du tout seul à sa
passion elle est d'ailleurs en train de
voir tout le fond du spectacle d'hier
est à l'affût oui c'est vrai ma cool
merci blanc dj la première abonné je
suis vraiment vraiment ravis qu'ils
savent ni tabulaire comment j'étais
content qu'on se rend compte que ça
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et s'est plaint
d' inique il le dit il faut l'écouter
elle abonne toi à la chaîne mais un
petit pouce en l'air commande fait tout
ce que tu veux et rendez vous à demain
17h pour le prochain mortal blog ciao